actually just in a small tangent on uh
going like what what do you uh from
everything I know she's an instrumental
a really crucial person to the success
of SpaceX in running the show she's the
president the CEO
um what uh do you know about her that um
uh sort of the genius of Gwen Shotwell
man my understanding is she's really the
glue you know she's the glue to the
tornado
tornado comes in and then she comes
around and just really executes on on
and and helps
you know a famous story is that at some
point Elon walked in or she's sprinted
into a meeting because Elon was actively
trying to cancel Falcon heavy saying
it's too far like it's too much
development we're it's still too far
away and this is like
you know this might have been like end
of 2017 or something and it flew for the
first time in 2018. so we're talking
like it's close to the end of
development you know there's Hardware
being built all this stuff and elon's
literally in a meeting telling people
they're going to cancel it and we're
going to move on to bfr or no Starship
um and just go full steam ahead on that
and she runs into the meeting and
reminds Elon we have X amount of
customers that have already purchased a
ride on Falcon heavy we can't delay that
you know so it's that business sense of
like we yes it's great to innovate but
we also have to pay our dues and and
make the money to continue our
operations and I think she's just a lot
better at
yes I think she has such a great
perspective on everything it really
seems like everything she doesn't I wish
she did more interviews because I would
love to hear more from her um but man
like it just hear that Gwen both of us
yeah she hasn't actually done them any
interviews right not really no she's on
like a TED Talk um a couple little
things here and there but not really
many interviews and I would just love to
hear like what you know what on a daily
basis like what is she doing to keep her
head on and keep everything so organized
you know it's
you know but yeah I my understanding is
that she she is absolutely integral and
does just a insane amount of work in
SpaceX yeah I mean the so it's the the
project planning but also the how the
teams integrate together and the and and
the hiring and this is the man I think
it's a lot of it honestly even just the
business making sure the money's flowing
in a positive trend more or less you
know that yes elon's obviously a money
guy but he thinks he's so I think Elon
is so risky you know he just loves to
throw it all in that he leaves little
margin for error you know he's he's been
really lucky with rolling his dice you
know especially like when he started
SpaceX and Tesla that was the ultimate
role of the dice but I think she's a
healthy balance to be like well here's
our you know operations and now we can
continue to do this without risking
everything you know and starship's close
let me be clear Starship is close to
risking everything already it's just
such a big fast-moving high-risk
developmental program that like
I I personally think you know SpaceX
would probably be fine if they shut the
doors on Starship and just flew Falcon 9
and Falcon heavy for the next 10 years
they would still be commercially valid
they could not spend another dollar on
research and development they could fire
I don't want them to fire everyone
involved in anything research
involvement and just ran operations on
Falcon 9 and Falcon heavy and they would
still be dominant for 10 years and they
would still have a business case and
they'd still be fine but
um they're all in like all chips are
pretty much as many chips as possible
are in